what percent of hello aliens would be
able to talk to us in our language this
is the question of communication
it actually gets the nature of language
it also gets to the nature of how
advanced you expect them to be
so
i think some people
see that like we have advanced over the
last thousands of years and we aren't
reaching any sort of limit and so they
tend to assume it could go on forever
and i actually tend to think that within
say 10 million years we will sort of
max out
on technology we'll sort of learn
everything that's feasible to know
for the most part and then you know
obstacles to understanding would more be
about like sort of cultural differences
like ways in which different places had
just chosen to do things differently
and so
then the question is is it even possible
to communicate
across some cultural difference
distances and i might think yeah i could
imagine some maybe advanced aliens who
just become so weird and different from
each other they can't communicate with
each other but
we're probably pretty simple compared to
them
so i would think
sure
if they wanted to they could communicate
with us
so it's the simplicity of the recipient
i i tend to uh just to push back let's
let's explore the possibility where
that's not the case
can we communicate with ants
i find that um
like this idea that
we're not very good
at communicating in general oh you're
saying
all right i see
you're saying once you get orders of
magnitude better at communicating
once they had maxed out on all you know
communication technology in general and
they just understood in general how to
communicate with lots of things and had
done that for millions of years but you
have to be able to this is so
interesting it's somebody who cares a
lot about empathy and imagining how
other people feel
um it's communication requires
empathy meaning
you have to truly understand
how the other person the other
organism sees the world
it's like a
a four-dimensional species talking a
two-dimensional species it's not as
trivial as
to me at least
as it might at first seem so let me
reverse my position a little because
i'll say well the whole
hello aliens question really
uh combines two different scenarios that
uh we're slipping over so
one scenario would be that the hello
aliens would be like grabby aliens they
would be just fully advanced they would
have been expanding for millions of
years they would have a very advanced
civilization
and then they would finally be arriving
here you know after a billion years
perhaps of expanding in which case
they're going to be crazy advanced at
some at maximal level but
the holo aliens about aliens we might
meet soon
which might be sort of ufo aliens and
ufo aliens probably are not grabby
aliens
how do you get here if you're not a grab
alien
well they would have to be able to
travel
oh
but so they would not be expansive
so for the road it doesn't count as
grabby so we're talking about expanding
the colony the comfortable colony so the
question is
if ufos some of them are aliens what
kind of aliens would they be this is
sort of the key question you have to ask
in order to try to interpret that
scenario
the key fact we would know is that they
are here right now but the universe
around us is not full of an alien
civilization
so that says right off the bat that they
chose not to
allow
massive expansion of a gravity
civilization is it possible that they're
they chose it but we just don't see them
yet these are the stragglers the
journeymen the so the timing coincidence
is it's almost surely if they are here
now they are much older than us they are
many millions of years older than us
and so
they could have filled the galaxy in
that last millions of years if they had
wanted to
that is that they couldn't just be right
at the edge very unlikely most likely
they would have been around waiting for
us for a long time they could have come
here anytime in the last millions of
years and they just chosen they've been
waiting around for this or they just
chose to come recently
but the the timing coins it would it
would be crazy unlikely that they just
happened to be able to get here say in
the last 100 years
uh they would no doubt have been able to
get here far earlier than that again we
don't know so this is reference like ufo
sightings on earth we don't know
if this kind of increase in sightings
have anything to do with action
i'm just talking about like the timing
like they're they're they arose at some
point in space time yes right
and it's very unlikely that that was
just to the point that they could just
barely get here recently almost surely
yeah they would they might they could
have gotten here much earlier
and well throughout the stretch of
several billion years that earth existed
they could have been here often exactly
so
they could have therefore filled the
galaxy long time ago
let's push back on that that's what the
question to me is isn't it possible
that the expansion of a civilization
is much harder than the the travel
the sphere of
the reachable is different than the
sphere of the colonized
so
isn't it possible that the sphere of
places where like the stragglers go the
different people that journey out the
explorers is much much larger and grows
much faster
than the civilization
so in which case like they would visit
us
there's a lot of visitors the grad
students of the civilization they're
like exploring they're collecting the
data but they're
we're not yet going to see them and by
yet i mean across millions of years
the the time delay between when the
first thing might arrive and then when
colonists could arrive in mass and do a
mass amount of work is cosmologically
short you know in human history of
course sure there might be a century
between that but a century is just a
tiny amount of time
on the scales we're talking about so
this is a in computer science and colony
optimization it's true for ants so it's
like when the first ant shows up it's
likely and if there's anything of value
it's likely the other ants will follow
quickly
yeah relatively short it's also true
that
traveling over very long distances
probably one of the main ways to make
that feasible is that you land somewhere
you colonize a bit you create new
resources and then allow you to go
farther many short hops as opposed to
long exactly
those hops require that you are able to
start a colonization of sorts along
those hops right you have to be able to
stop somewhere make it into a way
station such that you can then
support you moving farther
you